not sure whether it's a feel nervous or
excited or neutral kind of just feel
neutral I just had ramen so I'm feeling
full trying to stay awake with coffee
okay just a few more seconds it's gonna
be hard for me to read the chat while I
play I'm gonna focus as much as I can
thanks for the bits okay appreciate that
hopefully that will give me some
motivation maybe I'll turn the volume
off just so I don't get like the echo
thing oh thanks for the sub mood urbis
actually I want the volume on because I
know when like I like the sound when my
tongue it moves so we're playing like a
main line it should takes this is
playable Bishop f5 look splendorous I
could take on c3 you guys should take on
c3 I remember there's a kramnik Apsara
game where like he takes one c7 at some
points maybe I should play c6 so I could
play c5 Louie thanks again for the bits
but I do have to focus time on of
Sicilian okay that's an opening I can
play if I'm blacking efore let's just
play solidly expecting Bishop d3 hmm
Bishop b4 is interesting should be for
Bishop e2 I'll start with this some idea
of a 5 and then later c5 like a5 b5 c5
there's also b5 ideas
and you have 96 night c4 what to do I'm
moving way too slowly this is really bad
I'm used to playing slow chess let's
play
am I so slow okay the idea is to
maneuver the Knight to d6 it's better
placed promise ya b5 is coming I'll play
a 6 a 4 is gonna come it takes maybe
it's not so bad
I mean minority attack is kind of scary
but I want to get to the square and
Bishop g7 was gonna be passive that
might be necessary what to do take
sticks ah there's a trick or is there
Thanks so let's try 96 idea of takes and
rook c8 oh I also have 94 94 will be
better I can take with Queen I'm gonna
suffer it with some bad pawn structure
but that'll be ok I have an active
Knights I can take with pawn let's take
with pawn and keeping Queens on the
board cuz I might have some King side
attack I want to play rook out CH soon
yeah let's do this rook b6 is coming I
can't play c5 mmm
well I have tactics against a rook do I
takes up to five trying to make
something work take sticks Hicks it's
not a good start it's late let's move
not what I wanted
expecting rook b6 I'm gonna have to go
down upon there is two second increments
which should help so if this trip takes
a six
I play probably c4 aha let's play c4
call off the bishop protected passed
pawn might see three ideas it's actually
not looking so bad because we're okay
one Knight c3 it's looking very playable
I'll win the a pawn and I might actually
just have better structure pawns are
fixed on light squares but that's okay
they're pretty solid so do I take
there's multiple approaches here should
probably take with Rua now can I promote
the C pawn so soon probably not
okay f3 is coming wait c3 c3 just
winning oh no Keaney one oh it's so
close so one Bishop c2 very tempted okay
I'm not trying to provoke f3 because
then the light will be kind of stranded
yeah now I should see too I guess
threatening g5 to trap the night double
x clan takes okay I'm something up a
trap that if the pawn takes I have g5
there we go
I just trapped g5 is actually a good
move bishops move backwards squares are
covered how's the magic in provoking f3
I just have to make sure this pawn
doesn't promote I mean they might get to
a point well I'll have to meet with
Bishop in Knights
thanks for more bits uh yeah
g5 to start the stream can't complain
with that yeah I don't know if I can win
this so because I'm running out of pawns
pretty quickly
I play h3 you should probably play h3
okay let's start with this move attack
the bishop now each three king of 291
mm-hmm let's try and trade off the
bishops some Bishop e5 ideas its
activate the King
okay try and dominate the dark squares
that's not going to work though how do I
do this
let's try and get the night this way
mmm that's really annoying let's do this
move I could lose this this is not good
I mean yeah that's pretty easy draw
let's do this I think this is going to
be a draw
unfortunately swimming I don't [ __ ]
oh dear what's going on here
okay there we go
at least I have a blockade now Oh
what did you do this have to take I
guess yeah this is easy draw okay hands
in the draw as a messy I'm just a
fortnight children novice yeah that's
true I'm solid at least actually that
wasn't so solid but I didn't lose I can
butcher this morning actually you check
out my Instagram story see a beautiful
picture of Kombucha and a bagel and
smoked salmon and capers house Canadia
going Canadians going well I'm in Quebec
where most people speak French but I'm
getting by with English what do I play
hearing let's play London when does a
Montreal tournament starts it ended two
days ago but it went well well let's
find out of three here things might be
free for the bits I'll play Knight c3
preventing d5 maybe Bishop g5 just
developing trying to restrict opponents
d5 is coming I'll move back and then if
d5 I'll leave the tension play h4 here
typical idea Queen d2 will come with
tempo against this pawn yeah I'm leaving
the tension like at the Knight to e4 now
Queen d2 is a move I want to play and
either five is strong though mattify
very strong what to do
h5 is interesting maybe just Queen huh
takes takes it's like when d2 I might
just take back with Queen I'm leaving
okay let's play C 3 so e5 was probably
gonna come some day like today castle
take stick sticks doesn't seem great
though I could take yeah nothing seems
great I feel like I'm getting outplayed
again but that's okay I'm still alive
ones playing very quickly is h6 hanging
not quite because the Queen is
overworked it's like a castle Queen side
now I'm threatening to take h6 expecting
Knight take c3 now I have h5 position is
actually not so bad g5 what to do g5
looking for tactics
they afford it's very thematic that fort
is probably the way to go
blacks a bit underdeveloped I want to
create as much havoc as possible okay
let's take this lady for might see five
playable I mean G for looks kind of
simple just want to play g5 we're gonna
see two g5 s two games in a row could
happen again g5 is looking very powerful
cuz I just want to open files G files uh
the main file to get to the king
so Queen e7 I don't really care about 8
to g5 ticks ticks let's do it well I 5
what is a smooth so I have 9 of 6 if I
take oh it doesn't quite work it sticks
I'm gonna cook g6 and ends
it's a good stream but I'm gonna try and
win again g5 is one thing but winning a
game takes more than just playing g5 so
I've successfully opened the G file
I'm keeping initiative my DEA's rip g1
and then rook g6 I mean I could probably
pre move rook DG 1 but all that my
opponents realize is doom rook g6 coming
with idea to eventually open the H file
whoa does this move takes Queen h7 takes
I'm just winning a rook cuz I win this
thing okay
I'm winning the game I think oh I'm
winning the bishop in the end - that was
nice Vorenus yeah the bishop would fall
because Queen takes Queen rook takes and
then it's a fork and if Rick takes and
Queen takes it's also a fork I felt like
it was getting outplayed somewhere in
the opening but then like the dust
settled and the position became just
nice for White's like black traded off
all the develop pieces and then I turned
it turned out that like White was ahead
in development and e5 made sense cuz my
King was still in the center but yeah
black just lost a lot of time like
taking and then you need to move back
and then I got h5 with tempo and I kept
some initiative if you're just joining
it's titled Tuesday this is round three
I'm playing an IM from Poland
let's play the London
the last couple games I've been a bit
slow especially in the opening so I'll
try and speed it up I like my opponent
is thinking and moved to a c5 do this
d6 interesting d6 take ok I'll just play
the kind of standard London structure
it's interesting approach I'll admit I
haven't encountered this specific move
order almost at all I don't think Bishop
g3 Bishop e2 do I give away the bishop
hair probably u5 I could take and play
Knight c4 as d6 is a bit in my control I
don't know if that's relevant at all
could trade Queens Knight g5 is
interesting kick the bishop Knight e4 in
more control over d6 ok it's getting a
bit tense wait I just hung a night in my
opponent didn't take it what is this
travesty ok I can play this move I think
- my Knights just hanging on g5 I guess
my opponent just trusted me ok now I can
take with a queen or with Knights
probably the Queen and Queen b3 and
after rooty aids Bishop f3 try and be
solid
I rook to you one coming by they five
also coming now they five maybe queen
bee five let's play rip d1 fight for the
only open file Queen a three ideas
targeting some stuff maybe night see for
at some points it's a bit positional
maybe I'll move back and tickle the pond
not sure how locks defending Queen f6
maybe I have Knight c4 okay time is much
better the scheme 95 is always something
to consider
I like night c4 so many targets on dark
squares I'd see it
so now 95 looks attractive Bishop g5
also that's why 95 just some immediate
threats hey Tomo Somoza Toma Tomas a
samosa whatever your name is
thanks for hosting or reading appreciate
that toilet noggin in the chat with
toilet noggin emotes let's not get too
distracted I can take the pawn take on
b6 and then I'll be up upon and trading
pieces 96 Queen a4 is a move I mean g3
is also looking nice it's like g3
once the payee for maybe rook d5 it's
just a centralizing move preventing e4
planning rook FD one should defend the
bishop
kingi - and then he for maybe Bishop g2
safer rook b8 coming rook b8 I have 97
it's a nice move so e4 quite like cc4
doesn't quite work
maybe queen to Dew or fd1 I guess I
apply pressure I just take this
opponent's trying to complicate things
take that c4 defending
hmm that's a good move I think I can get
away with this it's looking very scary
though there should be three king h2
queen h8 bishop each three I just have
to consolidate my pieces are too much on
the Queen side
97 idea that's ideas were just trading
all the rooks when the Queen is
defending nicely if 93 I think I just
take the rook Bishop e3 King so if I
take the rook and trade 95 in the end
okay is there threat not seeing a threat
let's play this move if the Queen
defends a knight I just play Queen dicks
g4 yeah because tactics the majestic
fork Knights oh I also had 97 I should
have played 97 I saw the more
complicated tactic
okay let's end this in style Queen c8
and then 97 lot of things were missed
the scheme oh he should have tried to
induce Knight b6 oh that's a move I
still have to work for this what to do
[Music]
minds me of the first game let's push a
pawn
and b5 coming what where does my bishop
go okay I'm gonna set up this
configuration that way he can't win the
b5 hon then I'll win the F pawn play
let's move first I don't really want to
meet with the shipping nights I mean I
could if I have to but I'd rather finish
this some decent technique
um this works right I think it works
turning some fork okay the night should
be on before this is not the quickest
technique but I am getting the job done
there you go okay
what a game I mean that game started
with me blundering in nights my opponent
not taking it
thanks my boobs so I'm sure I'll play a
good player
okay playing this person oh dear
thanks for the bits all right let's
focus pretty sure I played this person
on on me chess several times Bishop f4
let's play a six
I should really study my theory here
like I was studying this not too long
ago where are they studying this we're
seeing some recommendation how to play
like some e6000 Bishop d6 s let's take
and play Bishop d6 and there's no 95
because d4 is hanging maybe b5 is
playable between d2
now way with 94 looks a little bit risky
maybe just Queen c7 just induce a trade
still no 95 not h5 here it's interesting
maybe I should castle first
so it's Queen g5 ideas curious which way
White will castle okay now h5 really
want to trade off this Bishop for White
Knight f4 is playable here it's
interesting Square some point I want to
play b5 Bishop d7 this LightSquared
Bishop is a problem for me your take on
d3 I take on d3 you played B 595 is
going to come at some points maybe just
96
I'll leave the tension maybe e5 at some
points putting a lot of pieces on the e5
square White's a bit jumbled H for a
while so wants to play h5 and this is a
time where it makes sense to strike in
the center so e5 ticks
yeah I think this makes sense in a 5 I'm
just banking on h5 e 4 just looks ok
my very first chess coach taught me that
if your opponent plays on the flank you
should play in the center I think I can
just take with the pawn extinct in my
structure this is a good version of
double pawns keeps the King safe and
each pawn now becomes a G pawns who
controls more squares
can cream of this okay times about level
so I'm guaranteed to win a minor piece
back and it's a question for a white
which piece he wants to give back you so
I don't need to make that decision and I
think whatever happens I'll have a
decent Center like the pieces might I
need to in the rooks are Abbott's
just misplaced I think my g5 so I have
to take the bishop there's a five a
tempo and Queen a three might be played
so I just have to watch out like getting
made Adan wants to take on d5 should I
defend
[Music]
okay let's defend should not have spent
that much time on that move Bishop II
for ideas
Bishop before now looks nice queen G for
coming
queen G for that sticks maybe can I have
to be careful not to get me then this is
very dangerous so should not have
allowed this mean that six looks
terrible but let's do it
things are getting very complicated 96 I
have Queen d7 with the I mean countering
the fork with a pin I mean g6 is now
very weak and my opponent again has to
make some decision I also have bitched
about five ideas a 96 Bishop f5 could be
playable it so takes aha
so I can take with you Brooke three
attackers on the night also the
light-skinned okay let's take here so
whites act material might win it back
but my not Queenie six okay so I this
move out of then Bishop tick so maybe
Queen c8 look strange Queen see it might
be the move though
looks like pin and I avoid I maintain
the pin if Bishop takes T six so Queen
takes e4 Queen Dixie far I have rook e8
d5 it's gonna be scary no matter what
slight time advantage what does this
move he's defending the Queen I can take
all materials equal here I'm not up
anything
let's play this move
actually I don't know
I'm not down upon i takes g7 we have to
trade it's probably a good move take the
bishop probably and then maybe 95 it's a
strong outpost for whites on e6 I have a
5 maybe Queen C 4 defend attack you know
time to draw arrows okay I get an
outpost to cutting off the defense so I
can maybe take the pawn next yeah now
all win the night I know thinking about
taking with her rook wait I'm gonna be
up a pawn at the end of this okay rook
d7 b5 or d6 rook e - yeah being up upon
ooh am i winning I'm winning both pawns
at least one pawn yeah this should be
winning
okay that's simplified quickly move
around in game time there should be a
technical win
I'm not sure you all put the reckon I
have seven firsts slowly but surely you
work my way up looking me here got five
first okay I have control over the
seventh rank maybe my rook should be
further away like they're in Kings you
for at some point maybe f55 looks nice
how to break through the rook here for I
guess probably g4 come in just need to
make sure my King always has sheltered
there we go
turning made into still threatening made
into there we go
well the game is scaring at some points
somehow i i weathered the complications
mm-hmm
oh it's cow spawn 99 gotcha okay that's
the name I know let's play this opening
again had decent results with it so far
93 is a move I would playing bullets but
not in blitz Bishop d6 over lean okay
it's interesting yeah this is a strange
move order I'll admit I'm not familiar
with this 97 move I'm gonna treat it
normally I'm okay if Knight takes g3
because I have the H file black probably
doesn't want to castle anytime soon I
might go for a four soon as well
probably gonna queenside castle and
black might do the same so I have the
bishop area but I have a solid position
there should be seven interesting trying
to evaluate if unlocks attack is kind of
quick if I Castle you play 95 let's play
95 transforms the structure a bit but
I'll have more space
and bishops are not so impressive yet do
I play Bishop b5 because c4 might be
coming or a six might be coming I think
I should play Bishop e5 it makes it a
bit more positional and it's just Mike
versus Bishop I'll Castle Knight belongs
somewhere else let's Viking me one
because always play can be one die lose
connection okay the thing went red for a
moment there my connection seems okay as
a stream went went out for a moment
okay c4 explosive couple been fine gold
moves in a row there so b5 before it's
coming that's hard to stop aphorism move
okay let's just put the night on a
better square
maybe now II for ya I'm dropping frames
I apologize
rickety - what to do my God will play
Rupp t2 I mean if takes I have to take
on d7 and I take and c4 is a bit weak
I'm just hoping there's no like clearer
infiltration for black like control D -
I control d1 d3 shouldn't be a huge
issue
oh no is can you get away with that
no he can't because I can take on D it
with check I was scared for a moment
that this is possible
okay so now I take care so c4 is a bit
of a targets probably can see - now so
mind you have playing Knight d4 Bishop
takes d4 and rip d1 that's interesting
Queen b7 ticks ticks looks playable also
ideas of Queenie to rip d1 looks safe
while Queen g35 to take rook takes aa so
I choose a bit fragile
hmm I don't know if I want to trade
rooks might have to though this
interesting idea to try and trap the
bishop yeah let's play this expecting
take some bishop f2 and then I play
Keeney two tix team 3 g5 takes
it's hard to figure out I also have g4g
for Bishop e3 f five now five the
threats in g4 I think is safer
so Mike versus Bishop ending so now have
five have to play I thought I also have
no I don't have it's fire fire now the
Kings coming to d5 could be a problem I
have nights yeah this 94 move will be
nice and in some lines I feel like all
three results are possible it's gonna
come down to sometime scramble a6 is
very weird
Oh defending okay I see so let's just
move up the king but Mikey was gonna get
to e4 before black it's to uh to d5 only
problem is there's bishops he won in
some lines by control f4 so you can't
easily access e1 I have b3 if necessary
a six I think lost some time but not
sure if I had anything better
yeah let's put the King here by Square
King power so now the bishops gonna try
and maneuver what to do
searching for ideas trying to calculate
the King pawn in Doom finite e2 and this
might just be a draw
Wow g6 I'll leave the tension plate B 3
B 3
Oh B 3 is 2 weakening let's move back
listen I teach for doesn't work right
away
now maybe not each for its finite h4 I
played g5 first fixing the pawn on g6
now here now I win g6
oh he had counter-attacks figure out
about that but I taken plane out of 4 oh
no I just defend was this just defend ok
not sure if black has any counter play
it's going for counter play though I
check there let's move back I think this
works I did by blocking on c2 I'll have
two passers a in the on the G pawns
should be enough
I wasted temple maybe that's annoying
today this oh that's a nice move I
wouldn't see for now but he wins this
pond what's going on hell I make
progress am I trying win this can bring
the king in okay let's take this push oh
man what's going on I'm winning this
definitely winning this
what a game war the game Wow
it's insane and game I thought of him
you draw at some point I thought I might
lose that like I think he missed some
chance that's crazy
game I think he missed a chance to play
when I played 94 I think this is maybe
like close to winning like the king just
comes in Wow
but we were both so long telling it's
[ __ ] okay thanks for the bits oh I have
a fortune cookie let me open the fortune
cookie I went to a Japanese place it's
weird because I've like I'm in Quebec
it's very french-speaking I've been
having a lot of Asian food but I went to
this Japanese place got some ramen
the waitress gave me chopsticks and then
realized I don't really use chopsticks
so then gave me a fork and then gave me
a fortune cookie I've never been to a
Japanese restaurant and it's given me a
fortune cookie oh my gosh look at this
there's three fortunes inside I've never
had a fortune cookie with three fortunes
it's just one cookie you see this I'm
not even like making this up so what are
the fortunes
okay dropped part of the cookie that's
not the best look oh my gosh all the
fortunes say the same thing look at this
who this nobody does it better than you
this one says the same thing
I've never had a fortune cookie with
three fortunes it's even in French look
at that I don't have a full screen like
thing but there's also this thing French
that's such a good fortune for this
tournaments oh my gosh I almost dropped
the other piece of the cookie have to
eat this now
yeah I'm terrible at like pronouncing
French words it says person a nail a
fait meal cable something like that it's
my only attempt speaking French on
stream okay let's play a Sicilian I'll
play a time on earth just for toxically
Nana pardon hmm coming up three let's
take and play this idea for a white his
queen g3 usually get some end game so
there's a slide Bishop c5 and 95 but
he's not going into it so let's play
this and you Rick see it coming it's all
whites considered slightly better but
it's very playable for luck Bishop
before a knight in 95
Bishop d4 probably have six is necessary
let's move 93 I news to play this move
Bishop f2 bishop wants to be on this
diagonal
okay so tix I have the bishop hair take
with Rooker pong ping pong let's go see
three ideas yeah move the bishop back
the bishop on c6 over defending the pawn
mobilizing my king
I give rook b8 also ideas of pushing the
a pawn
forgot about that move probably a good
move
okay g6 in question the rook g6 4k v
Bishop b5 a Ford bishop d8 alright let's
do it
have to rely on some intuition
it's a weird line rock a5 Bishop b5 so
yeah that's some that's reasonable for
whites maybe that's you know f6 doesn't
work so I should move the King it's not
so comfortable like Bishop Bishop g5
kingi seven yeah this is gonna be ugly
be a lot of pressure on the H file so I
have to weather the storm oh I forgot
about that move that's really bad
you have to play rough G Yates this is
really bad it's only a pawn I still have
the bishop hair - look on the bright
side of things
still ideas of pushing and I'm still
kind of solid there's no like glaring
weakness but White has just a lot of
activity
ah that's an idea
so why want some Amy maybe t65 Bishop g5
to Heidi six
yeah the threat was rocket-shaped so
there's some Bishop g5 e5 idea it's
interesting move do can I get away with
this
oh no the rooks hanging tough when I
take okay we get some optical art Bishop
looks terrible though take sticks okay
I'll have I don't have to kini seven
and this is really ugly it's gonna be a
miracle if I survive this only hope is a
fact that there's out the car bishops
oh there's Bishop e5 I forgot about that
what to do a high flagged
Oh what to do I was losing the opponent
played well that's the danger of this
line is this positional play on the King
site for whites it's a bit annoying me
maybe g6 is a just to weakening maybe h6
is a way to go house rough I have to
play more chess love to talk about tea
right now or drink tea but I'm a bit
preoccupied so playing an I am from Peru
playing another London I'll have a peer
it's like opening by each five so I
think after g5 I can play e4 hitting the
Knights you guys studied something like
this at some point in time
oh let's not hang G - I have h4 here
each were looks reasonable just trying
to weaken black structure a little bit
okay that's interesting so we could
trade a bunch let's trade a bunch Queen
h5 in the end Bishop b5 at some point
maybe I'll take in Bishop e5 I have a
center I gave away the bishop hair but
in some nice development here I want to
play queen h5 and just sack looks very
reasonable
let's do it I do the night of three
keeping some initiative because if takes
on c3 then Queen h8 so serious threats
I'm gonna have ideas of Knight g5 which
could be very strong
she Knight g5 is very close to winning
there's my e5 unfortunately then there's
96 does that work 96 just queen c8
that's a crazy line I'm calculating this
and then this and then 95 96 the arrows
are too distracting but it's fascinating
line Queen h7 in the end there may be
within Bishop takes c6 so Knight g5 95
96 Queen see it
I mean there's 95 that's insane that's
really insane I'm not sure if that
really works so also 95 right away
could just be more reasonable now let's
play this right away because I'm
expecting a 6 and then 95 yeah this is a
nicer version so I'm threatening mate
if 95 then 96 so beautiful because the
bishop and the pawn will be pinned
look at this move it's so beautiful so
so beautiful so I basically want a tempo
got 95 in for free cuz he six was just
um just losing upon
it's a sweet game so let's try and
finish this cleanly between see it I win
the bishop I'll just win material I
think oh I take the bishop so Queen C I
take the bishop Heaney 795 King takes c6
Queen of five mates in this case I can
win the Queen come in c7 when c7 then
when the Queen just want to be accurate
have a queen for minors just take the
Queen check in here queenside castling
coming at some points c6 anything better
I could take on f4 - no need to
looking for some breakthrough should
probably just move quicker play this
move and neither four will be supported
so two bishops for a queen five will
come the rook will come to g1 it still
takes some work this is actually not
easy
well let's not plug your queen let's
play this move now this is actually not
going to be easy and bishops are
annoying play a3 at some point to play
quickly
so look for some opening c7 can be weak
maybe Queen a7 ideas Oh check almost
works
just have to poke and prod come in from
behind
queen of fates
hmm
this is really not easy oh let's not
plunger again
rook takes that five I take with check I
try and come in from behind again twin
c4 as well let's get the Queen to c4 and
have six ideas with each one ideas
now I'm winning c7 I think so that's a
good trade
let's take your first probably regret
for one coming yeah then I went out
seven oh no I don't
mmm let's keep checking check it's come
from around clear this train rooks
just trying to gain time get this pawn
break in
terrible
I was a draw I felt like there's
something wrong opportunity towards the
end there
Oh such a good opening to at least I
didn't lose that I was trying 116 moves
yeah I mean I would have played on I
should I play queen c6 here and blacks
almost ins legs long yes there's Bishop
a5 no but then I wind up on okay it
still should be a draw but I wasn't
fortunate what did you I was a long game
well okay I didn't lose five out of
seven I mean going it back I mean this
still feels so bad not to win that game
it's like 96 like look at this move just
everything was working
it has good resistance from my opponents
okay max round is starting playing an FM
I'll play London again sticking with the
same repertoire
I don't think I'm in any contention to
like win the tournament too many people
with high scores but I'll keep trying to
grind away let's play a Knight c3
okay you have a berry attack I like the
fact my pone stinking castling is the
type of move it's playable but help
stabbed like preparation also help if I
had preparation here I know like in some
positions I should take might be five
doesn't make any sense
let's start with taking and then taking
here
so 25 yeah
what to do bishhh of d3 was also Bishop
e5 looks kind of interesting I'm kind of
just making stuff up hoping it's not
like terrible this could actually be
really bad this is really bad okay I
think that last game kind of affected me
what to do
do I resign do i rage quit or do I fight
let's fight
I could rage fight yeah okay have to
play King f1 at some point I mean
there's some compensation the black is
gonna have a massive initiative this is
not going to be fun f3 maybe then Queen
g3 let's play King at for him
okay let's go maybe g3 g4 is attacked
though and so what to do our gauge for
doesn't work
this is just really bad wait was i
thinking after G three ticks ticks ticks
and it's so ugly I have to do something
mm-hmm take with the night
Queenie for work H for if I'm holding on
to D for then feeling slightly happier
actually slightly less sad not have four
playable so watch out for a g5 I
probably should not have allowed this
night g2 is a move Queen d3
click windy 3i takes d4 maybe knight
takes g6 just try and confuse the
opponent
get away with this so g5 work h5 between
g4 Queen e2 core queen up three maybe no
this is all just bad any hope g5 work h5
Queen 84 I think I'm losing more
material and I'm wanted to play Queen e2
but there's a knight takes g3 so what to
do is f3f3f3 I guess takes takes it's
gonna turn out really bad but oh that's
really bad
still trying to fight I've created seven
ideas
maybe I should have thrown in queen h7
wouldn't have done done much though I
was rough I botched the opening really
badly there
what should you I guess we I have no
idea how many subs there are my pod is
not working okay I'll play a Stafford
gambit if white plays d4 please play you
for you know you want to Best Buy ah
come on let's play d5 let's play
something normal play a qgd I wasn't
even I would not have been able to play
budapest against this I'll play this a
six line or not play roof to be 897
interesting
okay so h3 prevented Knight g4 which is
usually the main idea 97 looks playable
take sticks f4 I could also just take on
e5 let's take on e5 and queen h5 I might
be able to take on g5 in that case or
just neither fates oh yeah this looks
very reasonable expecting probably takes
on you 7f 4 then I have f6 I might win
upon
what country is this Kosovo Wow
I don't think I've ever had Kosovo on
geoguessr isn't that nearer I might just
sound dumb I think it's neuro it's like
Eastern Europe right
Bulgaria should be near Bulgaria
austria-hungary it's around that area I
think I could be very wrong it sounds
like a country that which could be in
Africa I watched a great video on
YouTube another day I was from the the
onion it news that the u.s. like was
mistakenly sending money to Andorra
thinking it was like a third world
country in Africa of course it was like
satire news as was a great segment might
see five what do I do here I mean can I
just win a pawn like Bishop f8 green h v
g6
how is white defending this okay let's
take it
ah Bishop takes h7 very sneaky very
sneaky does that work take stick stick
Queen h5 King GA takes I don't have g6
it's annoying I can get the bishop here
it also just allow f4
I think I'll just get the bishop here
yeah I want to play g6 with those Queen
h8 mates
why are my pawns off center my
hallucinating
maybe I'm just hallucinating they feel
off-center what to do here rook just
can't focus
maybe f6 here at 6 Bishop e6 okay
there's something definitely really
strange going on because when the
squares highlighted it's like not
covering the whole region something's
off
could be the browser zoom but let's try
and stay focus yeah well what's going on
oh my gosh I have no idea what's going
on I just made it super large let's play
this let's zoom out there we go okay
but now it's hiding my time what am i
doing okay I still have the bishop here
thank God
let's play rook e8 safe and solid I hate
how my pieces are off center like the
bishop this is really annoying but let's
just play chess still see the position I
wonder if it's been this way the whole
stream and I just haven't know this I
play a fort here for ticks
it's interesting b6 if you've you work
here first
I wasted so much time stupid reasons
maybe now be 65 play b5 k c6 was gonna
be a weakness
I've worked c8 if necessary to play look
a six it's ugly
right before I take it I'm a bishop
probably back to d7 it should just be
equal but time situation is not pleasant
bring the King in we should put the rook
back on see eggs
you look a six ideas I came here that's
scary
let me put the rock on d8 some idea of
taking bishop f7 could also be solid
maybe this move by winning the exchange
rook to e3 is forest and I've Bishop c4
oh that's not forest I've this move and
then Bishop b3 trying to trap the rook
I should see to coming the king should
be on e6 that's interesting move I mean
White has at four on - that's scary
let's do this
I still feel much worse here just buy my
pawn bishop duel
maybe I'll go for a three I should bring
the King probably to f7 ooh
it's bad timing hey let's put the King
back put the rook back
okay so age six IMG six teams should
come in quickly
oh that's very strong have to go for
this I guess nothing else to do
have to pray for me
oh there's one trick to play Bishop e2
that's not going to work though it's
just going to sack back
okay well Bishop e2 here take bg5 and
forget fates I'll win the earth pawn
maybe yeah good move so what's the plan
I have to go for the rosin trap it's my
only hope no this is very imposing this
is very unpleasant yeah that didn't work
good game I mean I felt like I was
making some progress when I got the pawn
to d3 but it was just a difficult
position to play I forgot rookie three
existed as a move these obstacle are
bishop endings are very very tricky
usually both sides have winning chances
all three results possible I mean the
winner of this tournament qualifies for
speed chess championships okay Tim
either let's mix it up let's play e4
this game I played London this whole
tournaments it's time for something new
yeah Knight c3 c5 slay f4 someone was
asking for Kings gambit this is a king
scabbit with Knight c3 and c5 included
yeah this should be pleasant to play
just gonna develop
I'm d3 castling and so general like I'm
pre setup
and I'm developing quicker than black
tax just pushed some pawns as one night
develops I'm ready to Castle black
hasn't touched anything on the kingside
and I have a time advantage wow I wonder
if he's going for g5 I mean I guess I'll
find out
g5 coming ah 95 interesting so I can
check and maybe I just take just take in
black trading off the only develop piece
maybe castling I have a temporary
advantage so this is kind of critical
like what White's plan should be
castling takes just workout to comply
Queen d3 maybe Queen d3 preparing to
pressure the D file rook t1 coming maybe
even Queens like Castle incoming idea
later of e5 actually looks nice so he
wants to play b5 in b5 I always have
Knight d5 its Castle I mean I have so
much developments I could win the pawn
and then lose it right back if Knight g5
9 g5 looks nice
I want to remove the bishop so then I
can safely win the d6 pawn
Bishop g4 probably just ripped d2 and
then each six is coming I'm not sure how
much progress has been made be Queen e2
I'd you have a five
we need to twenty five a five let's do
it
unleashing the rook can always double up
if necessary to I keep the c4 pawn
defended so Queen b6 so now maybe 95 to
trade play 95 now do I take with C pawn
do I take probably should take with this
pawn just it's a clear advantage for
White's King g7 expected so rook e1 is
rook e8 let's play Queen d3 idea of
queen of five by my play g6
now it's gonna be hard to break through
I just pressure on on b2 I've Queen b3
I've C 3 V C 3 so there's a couple weak
points as d6 and there's an e file ie 7
in some penetration square
there's also h6 which in some lines
could be targeted with a move like Queen
d2 so I probably have to take if King
takes Queen e3 if Knight takes Queen III
still g5 I love Queen d2 also have this
move starting queen h3 or threatening
Bishop takes 86 very sneaky and also
ideas of this to target d6 so now I can
just take on each six looks solid there
might be some counter play for a black
but I'll be able upon extra pawn not so
impressive it's like the CC puns where
my extra pawn is at but I have the
doesn't take
turning each - I've 94 and you start
with Queen h3 and then 94 controlling
dark squares we need 7 it's kind of
expected Queen e7 maybe I'll check our
mate off-site Bishop g5 Bishop g5 anyway
counter-attack may be preparing Queen h7
of the night belongs on d3 just pressure
the bishop if I can remove the Bishop
from e5 and play Bishop f4 still have
some nice pressure okay so do i trade if
Queen h4 here Queen h4 looks nice try
and keep my dominance ooh
forgot about that move I have to take
yeah that's a very strong move to take
now maybe King here as dangerous
position any Queen's side down to the
Knights so I have my deep three I do
have night at 496 can be very nice I
think yes to play 27 oh that move you
take sticks No
[Music]
ooh what do I do let's go for this no
this is gonna be really good
I'll probably have perpetual or actually
maybe a lock defends each two in the end
that's so unfortunate but not g6 and
then so I'll probably throw a check and
then take okay I can't flag I could have
taken d6 with check so terrible okay I'm
playing for a win
clearly that could be a good move let's
take I think I'm safe
oh no I'm not getting mated oh no oh
I've Quincy three
so many plot twists let's take here the
pawn crush
this should just be winning or is it for
Queens on the board it's better be
winning I just have to trade all of them
off
so many queens to check Jack let's go
was he king well the game what a way to
end things was insane I was a nice
finish maybe I'll put just that game on
YouTube amazing finish for Queens it's
been a while since I've been that many
Queens I think it was pretty simple win
there's probably multiple leaves to win
especially when the White House
initiative for a moment I thought I was
gonna be mated like in this position
[Music]
here here I just yeah I thought I was
gonna made it here because this Queen
takes a to his mates
I saw Queen c3 with just enough time
yeah that was a tough game I opponent
like put up resistance I really like my
position from the opening hello to
YouTube yeah YouTube people hope you
enjoyed that trying to keep it up
thanks crows Mick for subbing for two
months if you're on YouTube you can
subscribe for free if you click the
button and dean Belapur thanks for
subbing yeah you too people hope you
enjoyed that i don't know if i'll post
just this game or the whole stream and
then cut it up but whatever is posted
smash the like button and I'll see you
in the future